hello and welcome to this video you this
is Grand Master L marmalade mammogram
often slide plus go against now he's
playing a serious opening this time and
you often play some yeah somewhat wiki
stuff not this time okay so interesting
Lyonya castles hmm I'm not sure about c5
in this position and he might try to get
it back here his pawn yeah I won't know
what do you play assist sex now probably
not knight c6 could be an idea okay I'm
not sure about this and just have to
invent it he here over the board yeah
this is the good thing about five minute
games in comparison to three minute
games as I had recently in that icc
tournament as sorry in that chest
outcome tournament and because that's
basically impossible to think for a
moment here you basically have to play
move move move it's just a different
form of chest three minutes okay so very
interesting here doesn't that look quite
good checking the on c3
Fields okay I'm threatening I mean of
course just hangs yeah ok so I think he
almost had to do something like lad
otherwise it looks very strange take
stakes I had also had good play there
I'm still a pawn up here in this
position it's not clear how he gets it
back ok I'm probably have to take maybe
he gets it back with this activity that
he definitely has now it's got some
active pieces but knight c6 isn't light
c6 an idea 95 takes it's still a fork
still of for quite ok tricky but the
rook is still hanging right so what
happens if i take it night before Bishop
takes and I came that's not super
convincing still feel it looks quite
strange yeah like I should have
something Queen da de that might might
keep the material three chicks I can
take this okay i can go 97 ok i try to
keep the material here
now 97 keeps it all night before me and
that before it's probably a bit more
active guess it gets 93 into into the
equation yeah that looks good there
should be six next now just at exit okay
well it can be six or so maybe you can
get the Pont back somehow something like
that yes i did some lift here for my
king I didn't see that move that's bad
okay i have d 4
TX night x and if you take c6 I takes
you three so should keep the advantage
night a for I have the chick okay check
maybe you can still takes you four here
yeah I probably can takes you four
should Bishop takes on it should takes
bishop tanks takes on f2 I can go to d
to them ok just this a this is census
are equal ha ha drown yeah maybe a fair
result I think I probably had a bit
clearly better position at some point
roughly here but I couldn't make it work
it was kind of interesting 95 yeah I
don't know if that was necessary but
it's a tricky yeah I mean if he takes
this this is definitely bad it hangs and
if he if he covers it I have 93 or I can
take and go back now here you might take
this okay janma this distance of course
better but can I win maybe this is not
Queen f6 instead of Queen DAED that
looks bad I am I wanted to give some
more protection to the five this is why
i went back here so rook moves and then
work the aid because i cannot take it ok
now i couldn't calculate that
yeah so somewhere he is a large
advantage this is this is nice but it's
enough for him now to to equalize mail
okay but this seems to be a mistake King
g7 still tries to win okay yeah maybe
okay be sure to five wins for black okay
why does that win because I just have c3
okay Jack I here promoting itm also
promoting okay that was easy check i
gave the check first Roxy wants two wins
and no Knight f3 wins Oh jack oh yeah
that's very nice yeah because this is
not working okay so that was what was
many chances that i didn't take okay
still a draw against the decent
grandmaster thanks for watching